foreign  [Music]  do you think there's any risk of a  nuclear meltdown  Russian forces are capable of anything  they behave like monkeys playing with  hand grenades they're Reckless and  stupid  [Music]  until we have this plant protected the  possibility of a nuclear catastrophe is  there  do you have any reason to fear that  Russia has plans to turn this nuclear  power plant into a nuclear bomb  [Music]  personally I don't have any evidence of  dirty bomb but I'm not allowed to walk  freely through the plant they're  certainly preparing something but what  exactly I don't know now to be clear  what he suspects Russian forces are  trying to do is dismantle the nuclear  plant so Russia so Ukrainian forces can  never use it again it's an extremely  risky Gambit meanwhile the iaea has been  granted access inside and so far they  say there are no clear signs of a  security or safety risk